the sessions the next stop is by
divyarti Mohan on Simplicity and
optimality and algorithmic advanced
okay uh hi everyone and I'm a poster
currently at Tel Aviv University and I
work with mihalfeldman and of course I'm
a researcher here for the semester with
the graph limits and processes on
networks program
so my work broadly lies in the
intersection of like algorithms
economics and Game Theory and like
especially I'm interested in
understanding the role of like
Simplicity or like the effects of
Simplicity in these regimes um and like
when simplicities can when Simplicity
can lead to like good outcomes so I will
briefly talk about like what I mean by
this initially and then I'll like give a
little bit more detail about like one of
my work
um okay so obviously algorithms are
everywhere and like they have changed
our worlds like drastically like we use
algorithms to find the best possible
routes to our destination match drivers
to passengers and even like operate
self-driving cars in busy cities but in
many of these sitting settings
algorithms are not just finding the best
possible solution while using the
resources efficiently they do so while
interacting with strategic or autonomous
individuals who have their own interests
so they might interfere with or
manipulate the algorithm so it's
important to design algorithms that not
just give good performance guarantees
but are robust to strategic behavior and
that's what the field of algorithmic
Game Theory focuses on and like my work
uh especially looks at the case Beyond
single Dimension settings so like I work
in multi-dimensional mechanism design
where optimal mechanisms can be very
complex and computationally interactable
so I'm interested in learning like or
understanding and designing simple
mechanisms that get good outcome that is
they are approximately optimal
and uh more generally the field of
algorithmic Game Theory uh like studies
how systems or algorithms uh perform in
strategic environments uh and like here
like my interests have been like mostly
uh in understanding how strategic agents
or like agents in a network interact and
like communicate and learn from each
other and what are the effects of these
like can we understand real world
phenomena such as like polarization or
like misinformation and information
propagation uh using these uh models so
this is the part I'm going to focus on
today uh this is Joint work with nikah
Brennan Lucy and Marcus Mobius we study
strategic communication with anecdotes
so we look at a standard economic model
of communication we have a sender and a
receiver and a hidden state of the
world's Theta okay so the sender is more
informed he gets some private signal
about the state of the world
and then he's going to communicate
something to the receiver and the
receiver hears this and makes a like
rational update she updates her belief
like in a Bayesian way let's say and
then she's going to take some action Aid
and both the agents are going to then
receive their own payoffs and like
importantly the payoffs can depend on
both the state of the world Theta and
the action taken by the receiver so the
sender here is more informed so there is
information asymmetry and he can maybe
like choose to say something to like
manipulate the receiver in some sense
because receivers has the agency to take
the action and that influences both the
sender and the receiver okay so for
example
um
you can think of uh the case where like
the sender is a newspaper and like uh
they want to like communicate to the
readers who are the receivers about like
the dangers of like long covert and like
maybe the reading this like the readers
are going to update their beliefs and
take an action on like how much should
we like wear masks or like whether we
should get vaccinated or not
and like in our model we are interested
in understanding this game when there
are anecdotes at play so by that uh I
mean that the sender is going to observe
some anecdotes about the state of the
world Theta and then he is going to
share one of the other Goods about like
that he observes
so here we think of anecdotes as like
immutable stories or like facts the
sender can share by from like whatever
he observes but he cannot make them up
he can't fudge them up he can't like
summarize them or anything he's going to
like share one of the uh n uh anecdotes
that he observes and like he'll choose
which one to like share it with the
receiver
uh so more concretely again we have a
sender and a receiver and a hidden state
of the world Theta so assume for this
talk the sender knows Theta and gets
side and like and gets anecdotes that he
can share he can't like share Theta but
he can share the anecdotes and anecdotes
are just modeled as like samples from a
distribution that is like centered
around Theta it's like noisy noisy
signals about the state of the world
with like the noise means zero noise and
like symmetric
and he is going to choose one of the N
anecdotes to share and then the receiver
will hear this and take an action and uh
we are going to look at the payoffs as
like coming from what the sender and the
receiver's ideal actions are going to be
so the sender is going to have their own
ideal point he wants the receiver's
action to be close to some theta plus
some some number Ms and then the
receiver has her own ideal point which
is like some shift of theta theta plus
Ms and like they both want to like
maximize their payoff or like minimize
the distance between the actions to
their own ideal points
okay so and the Strategic space of the
agents are as follows here so the sender
strategy space con contains like
communication schemes which will take
the N anecdotes and map it to one of
them so it's just a function that takes
the a realized realization of the
anecdotes and Maps it to one of the
anecdote and the receiver strategy space
contains uh action rules that takes the
communicated and effort from the receipt
from the sender and Maps it to some
action
okay so this is like the communication
game that we are going to study and the
high level questions that we are
interested in is what do we communicate
like are is there going to be bias in
the anecdotes that we communicate and
how efficient is this whole like
communication with anecdotes is there
how will the will the communication be
effective or like informative how
accurate is it going to be and also we
want to understand the other effects of
like who are we going to communicate
with like is there going to be belief
polarization or like is there going to
be some preferences for communicating
with certain kinds of senders or
receivers over others
so uh our results are as follows I'll
keep it very brief uh so we first
characterize like best responses and we
see that there is this very nice
equilibrium structure like a perfect
Bayesian equilibrium where the sender's
communication strategy is this simple
biasing strategy like all like he his
strategy is just going to be to pick a
shift of theta
like that's going to be some point and
to send the anecdote closest to Theta
that's it and the receiver is going to
best respond by like de-biasing this
anecdote and takes an action which is
basically going to be a shift of the
received anecdote okay so it's like we
have we don't have this as like a
constraint on
um on the communication schemes you can
the sender can choose any anecdote to
send but we see that this is a nice
refinement with a very natural property
where we can think of how how we
communicate like how there are biases in
our communication and we see that in the
equilibrium depending on how different
the sender and the receivers are this
shift of theta this in the juices or
like the bias of the anecdote of the
sentence chooses grows with the
difference between the preferences of
the agents and uh because of this
increasing like bias we also see that
the variance of the communicated skin
sorry communicated anecdote is going to
uh increase so there's a lot a loss of
uh precision as the bias increases so as
the p as the sender and the receivers
are getting more and more misaligned
like there is going to be more and more
information loss along with the bias in
communication
and we see that this is not the case
when the sender has a power to commit so
when the sender can commit uh like in a
sequential game the optimal strategy is
actually to choose an unbiased anecdote
that is closest to the state of the
world Theta instead of like trying to
bias it and like the receiver debiasing
it because that only leads to loss in
Precision so now the sender does not
even want to do that
so we see that like even in the simple
model of like communication there are
these very interesting insights about
like real world phenomena such as like
information homophily so recall that
when the sender and the receiver are
misaligned there is bias in at
equilibrium right there is a biased
anecdote that's being sent but since
it's still a realized signal the
receiver is still learning so in our
model the receiver is de-biasing it and
learning and there's information uh
learned but because of the loss in
Precision the receiver
um quality of information that she
receives is going to get what is going
to be worse as the center and the
receiver diverge and this affects both
the agents payoffs both the agents
suffer a loss when they're um types are
misaligned and we see that because of
this there are cases where the receiver
might actually prefer talking to someone
with very few observations like constant
number of signal anecdotes who's
perfectly aligned with her over a expert
who has like a lot of information but
since they are like a little bit
misaligned from the receiver they can
like
choose an extreme anecdote that has like
very
um bad Precision like even if the
receive the receiver is able to de-vis
it there's it's just such a noisy signal
that like she prefers listening to
someone with like 10 anecdotes who's
exactly like her over someone who's an
expert who's like misaligned from her
and I think like this sort of flick
phenomena well rationality can explain
like homophily is super interesting and
this is something I would like to like
understand better in terms of like the
effects of these kinds of informational
homophily and how they affect like
social network formation and like uh how
we evolve when we like talk uh in
particular I think like the co-evolution
of like beliefs and networks I think
will be like super interesting to learn
uh from all of these like endogenous
like effects
uh and like uh finally I'm just going to
like quickly also like mention that um
I've been also working on like some
mechanism design problems where um
uh we have like uh agents who with
interdependent values that just means
that like instead of having private
values that are independent of each
other our values for the outcomes are
actually very dependent on each other's
values mainly because I might not even
know how I value an outcome because my
value depends on the information
everybody has right sometimes my value
for an outcome depends on this private
information of the all the agents
involved so I'm interested in like
understanding how to design good
mechanisms under these settings and
especially in this semester I would like
to like explore like
um
settings where these interdependencies
are coming out of network effects or
like purefx so yeah so with that I'll
I'll wrap up let me know if you have any
questions thank you for listening
[Applause]
excellent talk
expressions
so the fact that you can add bias means
that it lives does Theta live in uh real
numbers or oh yes uh so we are assuming
that Theta is like
um any real number
um and the receiver actually does not
know anything about Theta so she has
like an uninformative like diffuse prior
Theta so we can add a bias and send a
signal closest to data
does it sort of generalize to a high
dimensional theater
that's a good question I think that we
didn't really explore that and I think
that would be a very nice thing to study
especially if my types are also High
dimensional and the way like I will talk
to people depending on like which axis I
am like yeah I think that's a good
question to study but like we have an
expert that yes oh I was also wondering
so the sender um uh so it seems like the
senator wants to not be too biased but
what if the sender is sort of
short-sighted knows knows when this will
end Maybe
you know can you repeat that question
sorry it seemed it seemed like in the
long term the sender will not want to
add bias right yeah so like in a
repeated game
um maybe because especially because
there is this whole
um I I think you can think of commitment
as reputation in a repeated game that's
basically what ends up like not making
sense for the sender to send a biased
signal but like here we are looking at
like what happens like in a One-Shot
equilibrium where um
so there is this very that what happens
is that
um there is a
tension between like uh the persuasion
Temptation that the sender is having
versus sending an informative signal and
it has a very uh unraveling effect that
does stop so the in equilibrium it
doesn't unravel to the extreme it
unravels to some point uh and so there
is bias in equilibrium yeah
yeah
let's take any other questions offline
um
thanks
so the last Talk of the session and uh
and the whole event uh is machine
learning on large scale